Speaker 1: It's great to welcome back to the
program, Chris had Nagi, the founder and CEO
of Social Engineer LLC and also an adjunct
professor of social engineering for the University
of Arizona, also author of the book Human
Hacking Win Friends Influence People and Leave
Them Better Off for Having Met You.
Chris, always great to talk to you.
Speaker 2: Oh, great to talk to you again,
David.
Speaker 1: So many might recognize win friends
and influence people to reference reference
to the great Dale Carnegie book.
So it sort of really should be.
It's important reading, I feel like for for
everybody, it contains a lot of interesting
information.
What is the connection between the title of
your book and the Dale Carnegie book?
Speaker 2: So I love that book, right?
I really do.
And like you said, I think it should be required
reading in school because it has so many great
principals in it.
But if some of us don't know, it was written
in the 1930s.
Right.
So it's a it's a really old book, and it's
just like an homage to Carnegie and saying,
Hey, I, I have some new principles that we
can use some new techniques for the modern
era that are all taken from from my work as
a social engineer.
And let's see how we could keep that same
principle here being kind to people really
getting to know them, learning how to communicate
but bring it to the 21st century.
So it's really an ode to him.
Speaker 1: And in the past, you and I have
talked about different ways in which social
engineering can be used.
I guess I would say for bad in the sense of
use to scam people used to defeat physical
security.
And you work in testing physical security
and cybersecurity at different companies,
et cetera.
But there's also sort of like another side
to social engineering, which is simply like
better understanding how to get along with
people, how to relate to people, etc.
There's a totally there's a flip side to it.
Speaker 2: There is.
And it was only after I was doing that part,
the security part for about a decade that
I said, I wonder what happens if I just use
the same thing I did to break in this building,
but do it when I'm at the checkout line or
if I'm just waiting for coffee or I'm at a
store and somebody is angry, can I defuze
that situation?
And I just started trying these things little
by little and without manipulating people,
without having to force someone into doing
something they didn't want to do?
I found that you can communicate with people
and get almost anything you want just by being
nice, kind and empathetic.
And that's how this book came about.
Speaker 1: I've said to people on my show
before and in other circumstances that one
of the experiences that most sort of leveled
up my ability to build rapport and relate
to people was working in sales at the now
defunct electronics chain Circuit City, where
I started when I was 16 years old.
And you had all sorts of different people
coming in, many already angry because of some
bad experiences they had.
You know, people who want to they don't know
whether you can actually help them figure
out what laptop to buy for their kid or whatever
the case may be.
It's an incredibly valuable skill to have
to know how to very quickly relate to people
and build rapport.
Can you talk about sort of some of the principles?
And again, we're not talking about manipulating
people.
We're just talking about relating to people.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
And I think that's a really important point
that last point you brought up, because that's
why at the very end of that title, I put and
leave them feeling better for having met you,
right?
Because the the mission is, yeah, you can
go out and use these principles for that.
You can and you can manipulate people.
You can get them to do things they don't want
to do.
But if you leave that one thought in your
head, which is anything I do right now, I'm
going to make sure you feel better when we're
done interacting that you're going to go,
man, that was a great conversation.
I like that guy, right?
If I do that, then I'm not going to manipulate
you.
All right.
So let's just think of Robert Cialdini principles
of influence so we could take one, right?
Let's use liking.
Liking is an easy one, right?
So he makes this statement that people like
people who are like them and people like people
who like them so I can fake it and I can be
all nice to you and smiley.
But then later on, you hear me go, Oh man,
I really hate that guy.
And now you feel bad.
You don't feel good.
So then you're like, Oh, he manipulated me.
He got me to do something I didn't even like
me.
That's not cool.
Or I can learn to say, I'm going to pick something
out about this person.
I don't know, and I'm going to be interested
in them, and I really am, and I'm going to
want to know more about you, and you're going
to tell me about that now.
Later on, you're going to think, Man, I met
this great guy at that coffee shop and we
had an amazing conversation.
Four complete strangers.
And it's that simple where you can use that
same principle.
You can manipulate someone, or you can change
the way you communicate and you can influence
someone and really communicate in a more holistic
way, building rapport and making friends that
may be short term or long term.
But either way, you walk away with an amazing
interaction with a complete stranger.
Speaker 1: Now, I think that there are many
I know in my audience, but out there in the
general public who they hear this conversation
or they read Dale Carnegie's book and they
say, I'm an introvert this.
Stuff doesn't work for me, this is horrifying,
this actually this is these are the last types
of things that I want to be doing, and we
do see actually that in CEOs, for example,
introversion is underrepresented relative
to the general population.
There's a question, right, as to how you have
sort of that.
What about that?
What about the fact that for a lot of people,
this entire way of thinking about relating
to others is just very unappetizing?
Speaker 2: Yeah, that's that's an awesome
question, because my CEO at social engineer,
he is a massive introvert and we always talk
about this because he's he's one of the leading
social engineers.
You know, he goes and breaks in the buildings,
communicates with people, does all the stuff
that we always talk about.
How do you do this?
How do you get there?
So the first step is you have to as an introvert,
you have to have a desire to change, right?
And you really do.
It has to be from you.
It can't be because I tell you to do it or,
you know, they hear something on a show that
has to be like, OK, look, I just want to try
something new because it's that desire to
step out of your comfort zone.
That is the first step.
Now, where I see a lot of people who are introverts
fail is they hear this conversation and they
go, OK, I'm going to go out and do it.
And they pick the whole thing, right?
I'm going to go out and do this whole thing.
And now it's scary.
Maybe they fail a little and then they go,
Oh, I knew I couldn't do it.
Don't do that.
Pick one thing.
Say, Hey, today, when I go into Starbucks,
I'm going to get one person's first name.
That's it.
Start small.
So I'm going to get one person's first name
and I'm standing in line and you're in front
of me.
And I'm an introvert and I go, Hey, is that
the new iPhone?
You know, I was thinking of upgrading, Do
you like that?
You know, is it good?
Do you have any problems with it?
And they'll talk your ear off and then you
go, Man, thanks.
Hey, I'm Chris.
You shake my hand.
I am Dave.
Great.
Now we could part ways and I accomplished
that one goal.
I asked you a question.
I got your first name now.
Next time, say now I'm going to get someone's
full name right and you give yourself little
incremental steps instead of saying, I'm going
to go do this whole thing.
And what you'll find is eventually it will
get easier and easier.
But if you're not naturally a person who likes
to just go out and talk to strangers, then
don't throw yourself in the deep end, right?
You start swimming, you stay where you can
stand still.
So now the little
Speaker 1: the flip side of this again in
thinking about your expertize in fishing and
fishing and you know, all these different
things is sometimes the reason people get
sucked into scams is because the person who's
scamming them has exactly the skills that
you're talking about right there.
Hey, that was a great experience.
I ended up feeling good about that.
I like this person.
They seem trustworthy.
So what about the other side, which is being
equipped to protect yourself from people who
may do exactly the things you're saying, but
with with with subterfuge, so to speak?
Speaker 2: No, that's that's an awesome question.
So here's what I tell people, because sometimes
I'll hear people give suggestions for protection,
but they they make us not human and we can't
do that.
We can't.
I mean, first of all, we can't.
You can't control your emotional output if
you're a person.
So if if you feel fear or if you feel happy
or if you see someone that you think is attractive,
your body's going to react in a way and you're
not going to be able to control it.
Right.
So what I tell people is to if you could stay
self-aware in a conversation and when I start
to feel emotional about something, whatever
that emotion is happy, fear, sadness, whatever.
To analyze quickly is what I'm being asked
to do next.
Dangerous or not.
Right.
So let's say I'm the introvert standing in
line with my brand new iPhone.
You come up behind me and you're the introvert
that's going to have a talk with me.
And you say, Hey, is that the brand new iPhone?
Like I was thinking of upgrading?
And I don't really want to talk to you, but
I'm now self-aware and I go, Why would he
asked me that?
But you said, Oh, he's going to try to upgrade?
OK, well, what you're asking me is not anything
dangerous, so I go, Yeah, this is the new
iPhone.
And now if you said, Hey, can I hold it?
Can I see it now?
I don't know.
I feel a little weird.
Y y is a stranger asking me to hand you my
phone.
So I'm like, Well, I don't really feel comfortable
with that with COVID and everything.
Sorry, but you know, I'll show it to you now.
I can be self-aware with that and say, you
know, I don't feel comfortable with that level
of interaction, but you're just asking me
about my phone.
You're not asking me for my phone number or
credit cards or anything, then I can continue
that conversation.
So it's a matter of staying self-aware during
the conversation to make sure you don't give
anything out that could put you in danger.
Speaker 1: And that's exactly I feel like,
and I'm curious to see what you think.
That's exactly what the this good scammer
social engineer is probably good at, which
is maybe even delaying the asks that raise
red flags until enough trust has been built
where the mark would say, I don't know.
It's been an hour.
I've known this person for a month and it's
all been fine.
And maybe that's where the difficulty comes
with the more sophisticated scams.
Speaker 2: True.
And you know, I just read a story.
It was about a couple of months ago this poor
widowed woman lost one hundred and fourteen
thousand dollars in a romance scam.
Didn't happen overnight.
You know, they were, quote unquote dating
online.
And this guy took her for a couple thousand
5000 and 10000 incrementally got more and
more and more.
A year or so into it, she's out one hundred
and fourteen thousand dollars, this poor woman.
Yeah.
So you're right, it's they they build the
relationship because the principle of is that
we talk about before from child dini or report,
you will give more to someone who you trust
more so they can't come up to you and say,
Hey Dave, give me a hundred and fourteen k
and you're like, Heck, no man.
But if all of a sudden we're best friends,
you know, we're we're we're like blood brothers
and you trust me with everything.
Well, maybe, maybe now you would part with
that if I really need it and you have it.
So they wait to build that relationship to
do the ask.
Speaker 1: Hey, to talk about something from
the last sort of year and a half related to
all of this.
What are we seeing in terms of scamming and
phishing, et cetera, related to COVID?
I mean, the one thing I've seen is calls sort
of like the Social Security calls, but related
to the COVID stimulus, we were seeing that
for a little while.
But that's it's sort of just a version of
something we've seen before.
What else are we seeing?
Speaker 2: So because this is such a global
thing.
Normally, when we see some kind of catastrophe,
it's very localized, like a, you know, a flood
in Louisiana or the earthquake in Haiti or
something like that where you go, OK, this
is localized and then they attack that group
of people.
Mm hmm.
This is not this is global.
So what we're seeing is that these attacks
are happening all over to everyone and they're
very fear based.
So see, you know, click here to download this
app to see who has covered in your area.
That's a big one.
They want to take over your phone emails coming
from your work, saying, Hey, we need you to
install this program to work from home.
Right?
Then you like the phone calls where this is
a huge thing.
Think about it.
People working in the office now you got mom,
dad and two kids all trying to find a place
at home to work.
So you're working from your bedroom, your
kitchen table somewhere else and you're working
more than you ever were before.
Now you get a call, someone that says they're
from it.
Hey, listen, we got to put a patch on your
machine so you can connect to the VPN's while
you're, you know, at home and people will
install programs.
And this is how we're seeing major breaches
occur.
Phone, email and SMS have gone through the
roof.
And now you add to that that Verizon, T-Mobile
and AT&T have all been breached in the last
12 months.
Your phone numbers out there, my phone number
is out there.
This is why we're seeing an increase in phone
calls and text messages all over.
Speaker 1: Is there any are there blanket
recommendations that take people out of having
to make sort of like one on one decisions
as frequently like, for example, I no longer
pick up my phone at all unless I know exactly
who's calling me, and it's for a bunch of
different reasons, including that people who
don't like me have found my phone number.
Yeah, but but also because overwhelmingly,
if I don't recognize the number, if it's a
real call, they're going to leave a voicemail.
And if it's not a never hear back, so, so
like that would be one thing that I do.
Are there other blanket things everybody can
just make regular practices?
Speaker 2: Yeah.
These will seem a little technical, but I
will say them just because I think that's
a very important topic.
First is, I encourage everyone to use a password
manager.
Mm-Hmm.
Because the issue with the phone calls and
stuff is eventually we're going to answer
a call or we may fall for something.
But if we use a password manager, then we
don't have the same password on every website.
Yeah, and they're easy to change and control.
But even if you do that, the next thing is
vitally important, and that's to use multifactor
authentication on everything that allows you.
And if you have a choice, don't use the one
that sends you a text message using one that
lets you use an app, you know, like Duo or
Orthe or Microsoft Authenticator or something
like that, because that they need to have
access to your physical phone in order to
get that.
And if they have that, you already have bigger
problems, right?
So those two things alone and there's a ton
of others, but those two things alone could
save so many people.
And then the third thing I'll say, and this
is something that we can do for free in America,
which is you could put a freeze on your credit
with all three major credit bureaus.
Right.
And you can do that.
You don't have to pay a service.
It's easy.
It takes five minutes and you can unfreeze
it in five minutes.
And I suggest everyone do that because if
you have a password manager, multifactor authentication
and your your account is locked, people, even
if they steal your data, they're not going
to be able to use it.
So that keeps you from having to worry that
I just mess up, that I give someone the wrong
thing and it can keep you relative as nothing
will keep you hacker proof.
But it could keep you relatively safe.
Speaker 1: Now, in terms of just the incoming
phone calls, is there.
Sometimes you get legit phone calls because
there really has been, you know, your credit
card calls because there's a charge they want
to confirm or I don't know if banks really
call people frequently.
My bank doesn't call me, but I'm guessing
banks make phone calls, sometimes for real.
So is there some overarching principle that
can be applied to any incoming phone call
to prevent falling, even if it's one out of
a thousand that you fall for?
Speaker 2: Yeah, so I do exactly what you
said, which is I let them go to voicemail
even if it looks legit or if I do pick it
up.
And let's just say it's my bank and they go,
Hey, this is your bank.
We have some weird charges we need to verify.
Yeah, I say, Hey, I can't talk right now.
I'll call you back.
I do not call the number on the phone.
I take my card out of my wallet.
I call the toll free number and I say, Hey,
someone just called me from the bank saying
there were some weird charges I need to verify,
right?
Because I know that I'm talking to the real
bank because I called you.
But when you call me, I don't know.
And if they just start trying to verify information,
Heckman, with some of these breaches, they
have all of that, so they can sound super
legit.
Sure.
You know, so I just and don't ever call a
number they give you.
Just yesterday, I had a friend of mine who
got a call, someone saying they're from Amazon,
and they were helping them try to complete
a purchase on the account.
And they were they needed them to install
a program.
They didn't fall for it, but they gave them
a number and he called the number back and
someone picked on no Amazon.
How can we help you?
Right, right.
Even have people answering the phone with
the, you know, the numbers that they're giving
out.
So you can't trust it if they give it to you.
But if you call a legitimate number, then
you can trust it.
Speaker 1: Another one I've seen gotten recently
is I got an email saying, Hey, we just charged
you 40 bucks for the something you ordered
and of course you go.
I didn't order that.
I got to go and get a refund.
So then you look at the info on the email
and of course, if you called, my guess is
they would say, Oh yeah, what was the credit
card number?
You put it, and then you're off to the races?
Yeah.
Speaker 2: And if you think about that sounds
so legitimate, right?
Because if I call into an actual vendor, like
if I call my bank right now, they're going
to say, please verify the account you're calling
about, right, they're not going to give me
the account.
They're going to ask me to verify it.
So I'm going to legitimately give them my
account number.
Sure.
Which could be my credit card.
So if I call what I think is my bank and they
go, Hey, to look you up, we need to verify
your identity.
I need your full name, your account number,
your Social Security.
That sounds all legitimate, right?
So people will give it over.
And what they don't know is that if you didn't
call, if you didn't initiate that call, there's
no way for you to verify that you're speaking
to the actual company, that actual person.
Right, right.
So I always say the best practices you have
to initiate the call, you know, unless there's
some solid proof like, you know, you're standing,
you're you're on the phone and they're verifying
with you enough that you feel comfortable
with that or they're not asking you for personal
details.
I still really just I'd rather just pick up
the phone and call them back.
Speaker 1: Agreed.
Agreed.
We've been speaking with Chris Had Nagai,
founder and CEO of Social Engineer LLC.
The book is Human Hacking, Win Friends, Influence
People and Leave Them Better Off for having
met you.
Chris, always appreciate your time.
Thanks, David.